pour l'info et là il enlève son
pilou-pilou
du matin elle est là elle a quatre
couches d'épaisseur parce que la froid
c'est dur pour moi du mois d'octobre
jusqu'à fin mai pour moi c'est con
[Musique]
il est 14h en plein cœur de Paris les
fans de Snickers très nombreux sont à
l'affût si son père de naquère Max 95
Cortez doivent être mises en vente dans
la capitale les coordonnées GPS du lieu
de distribution viennent d'être révélés
sur ce bus qui tente de se frayir un
chemin une adresse jusque là tenue
secrète malgré quelques fuites oh petite
consolation à peu près ce que se prendre
pour des princesses là en descendant les
champs toutes les deux dents dans une
petite voiture
ça peut marcher on sait jamais ces
opérations commerciales appelées drop
sauvage suscite de plus en plus
l'hystérie elles sont légales mais
doivent être déclarées auprès des
mairies une obligation qui n'aurait pas
été respectée à Paris alors sachez qu'on
ne sort pas un DM d'un tel événement
regardez le tweet de David Belliard
l'adjoint à la mairie de Paris résultat
de cette campagne illégale si blessé un
mineur piétiné des bagarres
l'irresponsabilité de Nike et de son
agence de pub est totale certains auront
quand même réussi à acheter leur
précieuse basket au prix de plusieurs
heures d'attente les 16h52 elle est là
la fameuse
magnifique
on faisait la queue dans Paris pour
acheter le dernier Victor Hugo les
incunables aujourd'hui c'est des paires
de chaussures le monde a bien changé et
on se bat pour une paire de chaussures
il y a toujours Pascal pour nous
rappeler les vrais les vrais valeurs
[Applaudissements]
après ce moment nous allons vous
proposer Marie Laforêt il a neigé sur
yesterday
le soir
parce que c'était un peu violent en fait
le palais de Buckingham vient de
l'officialiser le prince Harry sera bien
présent au couronnement de son père le 6
mai prochain à Londres ce matin la
nouvelle fait quelques heureux je suis
ultra fan de Harry je suis toujours
contente de le voir pour être honnête
ête pour
marrant vraiment l'histoire que Madame
reste là-bas que lui vienne que oh là là
ils vont encore en faire un livre ou un
documentaire oui oui on verra ça mais
les médias anglais en tout cas ça les
passionne acheté par Harry et Meghan 15
millions de dollars
à l'intérieur tout le confort d'un 5
étoiles avec 9 chambres et pas moins de
16 salles de bains
[Musique]
et ses produits ménagers récurer
elle-même ses salles de bain et quoi de
mieux pour oublier le contexte français
du moment que de
s'y coller une dernière fois et cheese
une dernière après je rentre chez moi je
suis pas retourné depuis des jours je
sais pas dans quel état je vais
retrouver ça mais jusqu'au bout le
président aura profité de sa Smartbox
évasion
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je vais rencontrer Madame la
mère mais on a rien à se dire bon on va
improviser
un lieu visé pour la première fois ce
matin à Paris
le siège de LVMH symbole des grandes
fortunes françaises a été envahie par
les manifestants
[Applaudissements]
au bout de quelques minutes ils ont
finalement été évacués en 2022 près de
50 milliards d'euros d'un des mises à
Sion ont été versés par les assurances
et mutuelles c'est beaucoup mais toute
garde les reins solides AXA
6,68 milliards d'euros de bénéfice net
en 2022 alliance
6,74 milliards d'euros
de l'argent il y en aide
on vient symboliquement et pas
typiquement dénoncer et justement donner
une idée au gouvernement une bonne idée
voilà vous cherchez de l'argent pour
financer les retraites et ben prenez-les
dans les poches des milliardaires a
commencé par Bernard Arnault
fait ma place au paradis
premier détourne à 200 mètres carrés
à l'étranger la nouvelle gaffe de Joe
Biden hier soir en déplacement en
Irlande le président américain dans un
peuple confondu l’équipe de rugby des
All Blacks avec les Black And Dance noir
et fauve en français une unité militaire
britannique qui a combattu les
indépendantistes De l'iral armée
République finirlandaise il y a un
siècle une bourde qui fait tâche dans un
voyage placé sous le signe de
l'apaisement
c'est la dernière fois que vous voyez
sous cet apparence gardez demain
Monsieur le Maire devient officiellement
madame la mère l'annonce a eu lieu ce
matin aux agents municipaux
j'étais sur une intention très forte de
démissionner voir de déménager
vous savez on dit
vivons heureux vivons cachés on va tout
compte fait j'ai décidé de vivre heureux
et pas cacher
[Musique]
vous êtes marié avec Rémi qui est un
ancien candidat exactement vous êtes
manager dans un magasin de fruits et
légumes vous habitez à Paris dans le 14e
vous votre rêve avec vos gains si vous
restez vous incrustez dans l'émission
c'est de construire un dressing pour
ranger ses fantastiques tenues de drague
à 63 ans Alain Zabo laisse place à
Estelle Zabo changement de genre et
d'identité assumer
on peut avoir une différence et avoir
des fonctions publiques politiques
qui peuvent être acceptés et en fait
aujourd'hui le sentiment que j'ai c'est
plutôt la fierté
d'avoir
eu confiance en moi le cadeau a rendu
fou tous les transphobes du pays qui ont
appelé au boycott de la budlight en la
versant courageusement dans l'évier où
en achetant des palettes entières pour
rouler dessus avec un rouleau
compresseur